ESP isn't real.
And no, you don't
have a 6th sense.
You're just going to
crush all my hopes
and dreams like that, huh?
Yeah, well, if you
had a 6th sense,
you'd know that I secretly
love to crush hopes and dreams.
You don't need ESP to see that.
Hey, everyone.
Lacy and Anthony here.
You've heard of ESP, right?
It stands for
extrasensory perception,
and refers to the ability to
pick up things with your mind.
As opposed to your ears, eyes,
nose, mouth and skin, which
obviously have nothing to
do with the mind, I guess.
Clearly, clearly.
ESP is, in a nutshell,
knowing something
that isn't immediately obvious.
For instance, you're sitting
next to a dude on a train
and you sense that he's
been in a car accident.
Or that he murdered someone.
Right.
Or murder detection, which
is a very useful ESP skill.
Despite the fact that more
than one in three Americans
believes in it, a year-long
study published in Plus One
this week is ruling out the
possibility of a 6th sense.
In the study they
found that it's true,
people who claim to have ESP
are picking up on something.
But it's not because
they're psychic.
Right.
It's because, for instance in
the case of the murdery jerk
on the train, you might
have subconsciously
noticed a fleck of
blood on his jacket.
We're intuitively processing
what we're seeing,
and our mind draws
some conclusions.
The catch is that
we don't consciously
realize that our sense is peaked
because of the blood, which
leads some people to attribute
it to psychic ability.
Other examples
might be registering
scars on someone's
face and knowing
that something bad
probably happened,
or registering that your kids
are really quiet, so they're
up to no good, or picking up
on subtle communication cues
and predicting that a
couple is about to break up.
The brain does a lot
of tricksy things.
The more of these paranormal
studies that come out,
the more I realize I
can't trust my own brain.
It's a little frightening.
How did they go about the study?
Well, it all started
with a student
who claimed to have a 6th sense.
The lead scientist wanted to
figure out what was going on.
The team showed student
participants an image,
gave a one-second pause, and
then showed another image.
And sometimes, the second
image was the same.
Other times, it had
a very subtle change.
And when the image
changed, the students
had no idea what
change, they just
knew that something
more was there.
Amongst those students who
picked up on the change
that they couldn't
explain, some said
it was because of
their 6th sense.
So essentially, the
researchers found
that what people are
calling the 6th sense
is information that we
aren't consciously aware of,
or can't verbalize.
This happens because
the brain is always
taking sensory metrics,
visual cues, [INAUDIBLE]
cues, faint sounds
in the distance.
They're constantly
being registered
in what is essentially
a giant, constantly
running database in your brain.
And only when the information
is of immediate concern or focus
do we really draw on all
that sensory information
that we're subconsciously
receiving from our environment.
I love the way the researchers
describe this, by the way,
like an abstract painting.
You looked at it and you're not
really sure what you're seeing,
and yet you get some sense of
what the painting is about.
It's like magic.
Except it's not
magic, it's science.
It's science magic.
No, it's just science.
Thanks for joining us
for D News, everyone.
What psychic skill do
you wish you possess?
Oh, I like the one where
you can start fires.
And I also like the one
when you turn invisible,
because then you start
the fire and no one knows.
OK.
So tell us about
it in the comments.
And if the studio hasn't
burned down by then,
we will be back with
more science updates.
And if it does burn down,
you won't know who did it.
Yeah, we're gonna
know who did it.